Encryption is the most often
used cryptographic operation.
It is a process of
converting data into a form
that is unintelligible to
the unintended or unauthorized party.
The authorized party can
reverse this process.
That is, converting the data
into the intelligible form.
Record the readable data,
the plaintext and
the unintelligible data, the ciphertext.
So encryption, then, is the process
of converting plaintext data into
ciphertext, and
decryption is the reverse operation.
That is converting
ciphertext into plaintext.
Notice that,
in order to perform decryption,
the authorized party needs
to have the decryption key.
There's a one-to-one mapping between
a plaintext and a server text, so
that the decryption process can always
get back the original plaintext.
Encryption protects
data confidentiality,
because only the authorized
party with the proper secret,
we call it a key,
can decrypt and read the data.
Encryption also provides
other security services.
These include integrity checking,
that is to make sure that
there is no tampering of data.
It can also assure
authenticity of message.
That is it can verify
the authorship of the message.
It can also provide authentication.
That is, to make sure that the party
that you are communicating
with is not an imposter.